[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsables del
programa de france 24 que los invita a
dar una vuelta al mundo de la mano de
nuestra red de periodistas el flujo de
gas natural a través del gasoducto nord
stream que conecta directamente a rusia
con alemania a través del mar báltico ha
sido suspendido debido a mantenimiento
aunque se supone que la interrupción
debe durar solamente 10 días berlín teme
que moscú decida simplemente cortar
definitivamente las entregas de gas algo
que perturbaría seriamente su economía
el país se necesita urgentemente
abastecerse de gas tanto para su
industria como para la calefacción de
cara al próximo invierno y para ello
alejándose de sus objetivos climáticos
alemania decidió reactivar algunas de
sus centrales de carbono y utilizarlas
para generar electricidad con el fin de
ahorrar combustible más detalles en el
informe de nuestros corresponsales en
alemania
cuando se ve salir vapor de las torres
de refrigeración de text back significa
que hay una escasez de electricidad en
alguna parte de la red esta es una de
las centrales eléctricas de reserva
alemania solo se reactiva cuando es
necesario remover o la algún problema
técnico
normalmente esta central generadora solo
se utiliza en casos de emergencia por
ejemplo cuando hay una fuerte ola de
frío estaba previsto que cerrara a
finales de este año pero con la
repentina escasez de gas ruso ese plazo
se amplió hasta 2025
a pesar de su tamaño y complejidad esta
central puede reactivarse conectarse a
la red en solo 10 horas nuestros
empleados están de guardia en todo
momento a naturales con un chiste para
reducir su dependencia alemania está
reviviendo al carbón no es una opción
atractiva pero sí pragmática sólo las
centrales de carbón de la región del
sarre pueden cubrir un 6 por ciento de
las necesidades de electricidad
no sabemos si putin seguirá
suministrando gas tras las reparaciones
del gasoducto nord stream 1 tenemos que
proteger la red y podemos hacerlo con
nuestras estaciones de carbón al menos
15 centrales eléctricas de reserva
podrían estar funcionando a pleno
rendimiento a finales de verano lo que
amenaza a los objetivos climáticos de
alemania pero los habitantes de esta
región minera no se quejan
al menos tenemos una alternativa sin eso
estaríamos perdidos
es la opción menos mala por unos años
más
la magnitud de la crisis energética dejó
al país con poco margen de maniobra
alemania está pagando con creces su
adicción al gas ruso siempre hemos
advertido de esta dependencia y ahora ha
llegado lo peor tenemos que hacer todo
lo posible para alejarnos del gasto y
del carbón tenemos que desarrollar las
energías renovables lo más rápido
posible y ahorrar energía la proporción
de electricidad generada a partir del
carbón en alemania ha vuelto a subir un
tercio pero el gobierno insiste en que
ese retroceso no afectará a los planes
de abandonar definitivamente la energía
del carbón para el año 2030
un eventual corte total del gas ruso a
alemania sería consecuencia de las
tensiones generadas por la guerra en
ucrania un conflicto donde las tropas
rusas siguen ganando terreno en la
región del donbass después de tomar el
total control de la provincia de lugares
que ahora los bombardeos se concentran
en la provincia de daniel ciudades como
crematorio backwoods islas se encuentran
cada vez más en la primera línea de los
combates en curso algo que deja a
cientos de civiles en un terrible
peligro ya que en la zona de los ataques
se intensifican más que nunca el
siguiente es un informe de luxe trago
acaba vid italiana
en el hospital número 3 de crumb atroz
ahora sólo hay una especialidad médica
trauma los únicos pacientes que siguen
aquí son los que aún no están los
suficientes estables como para
trasladarse al oeste hacia la zona de
seguridad como jacob herido por la
metralla en un bombardeo ruso
mi mujer ha muerto mi hijo está en el
territorio ocupado de cree mina no sé
qué pasará después
no se consideró bueno
muchos médicos se han marchado y
voluntarios de otros lugares de ucrania
lo sustituyen a corto plazo suelen ser
especialistas en heridas en la cabeza
bastones
de las explosiones de los restos del
proyectil vienen de arriba y si los
soldados militares tienen casco entonces
de alguna manera los protege pero los
civiles tienen muy pocas posibilidades
a pesar del peligro los civiles siguen
apuntando sea la defensa territorial de
ucrania y saber cómo tratar las heridas
del campo de batalla es una de las
partes más importantes en su formación
si la heridas en el brazo no puedes
saber exactamente dónde estás así que
tienes que poner el permitir en lo más
alto posible del brazo todos estos
voluntarios dicen estar listos para
cumplir con su deber en el frente por
otros millones me importa mi ciudad esta
es mi patria no quiero que los
separatistas estén aquí en tomar jugosos
otros optan por ayudar en la situación
humanitaria como natalia que coordina
tanto la ayuda como las evacuaciones de
civiles al menos cuando puede o no
quieren evacuar tienen miedo no quieren
vivir en estas condiciones
las autoridades de donets han estado
continuamente a la población a huir tras
los bombardeos diarios desde la caída de
delitos y chang en la ciudad de bach mut
solo quedan 5.000 habitantes muchos de
los cuales son ancianos y carecen de
recursos para marcharse ucrania está
haciendo lo que puede para evitar la
invasión de rusia sin embargo cualquier
ayuda que venga de más lejos puede
llegar demasiado tarde para muchas
partes de doñetsk desde que rusia tomó
el control de la vecina lugar ha seguido
presionando hacia el oeste
después de la decisión de la corte
suprema de derogar el fallo de roe
versus wade que garantizaba el derecho
al aborto a nivel federal muchos
estadounidenses están haciendo acopio de
la pastilla de emergencia también
llamada píldora del día de despacho las
ventas en algunos negocios se han
multiplicado hasta por cinco tras el
fallo del supremo un tribunal donde la
mayoría de los jueces es de corte
conservador desde nueva york con nuestra
corresponsal de mamen sala nos trae la
historia
esta es nuestra área de recepción
cohen es uno de los propietarios de
estos almacenes donde venden productos
farmacéuticos como la pastilla del día
después de juan la marca plan b está
aquí tienen hasta cinco marcas distintas
y tenemos más de la marca my shoes aquí
porque aquí se enteraron de que la corte
suprema había limitado el derecho al
aborto porque las ventas se dispararon
en su página web
nos levantamos y vimos cientos de
pedidos de pastillas de emergencia y fue
cuando dijimos algo no está bien
consultamos google y vimos la decisión
del supremo
desde entonces no hay descanso miles de
estadounidenses están comprando esta
píldora la gente está comprando está
almacenando porque no saben qué va a
pasar hoy ha sido el aborto pero mañana
podría hacer las pastillas de emergencia
lo que prohíben la gente quiere estar
preparada y si antes se compraba una
media de dos pastillas por cliente ahora
están acumulando y la media por pedido
es de cinco o seis cajas este es nuestro
chico de fe de escaneando los pedidos
cada día salen de este local 1200 cajas
5 más que antes de conocerse el fallo
del supremo la mayoría con destino a los
estados más conservadores donde prohíben
el aborto ante el aumento de la demanda
a algunas farmacias en el país como la
que ven detrás de mí han limitado el
acceso a esta pastilla a un máximo de
tres por cliente para evitar la escasez
de existencias por eso en muchos
establecimientos la píldora se guarda
bajo llave como si fuese oro en otros ya
ni siquiera quedan y en la farmacia de
marta las cajas que hay también están
así de protegidas es increíble que
tengamos que vivir esto pero es un
reflejo del miedo que hay entre las
mujeres en esta sociedad porque no
sabemos qué va a pasar en un futuro y
por eso cohen ya se prepara este mes ha
doblado su pedido a los fabricantes de
píldoras para asegurar el stock del
producto más buscado por estos días en
eeuu
pakistán es uno de los países en primera
línea del cambio climático en esta
nación de 220 millones de habitantes
específicamente en el sur del país se
encuentra la ciudad más caliente del
mundo hablamos de jacobabad allí las
temperaturas son tradicionalmente muy
elevadas este año se ha alcanzado un
nuevo hito en el punto más álgido de la
ola de calor de mayo se registraron 51
grados celsius en esa ciudad una
situación infernal para los habitantes y
que amenaza con convertirse en la norma
consecuencia de los estragos del
calentamiento global informe de la
igualdad y sonia que salí
el calor es abrasador en la cuba but
casi insoportable el termómetro marcó 51
grados el pasado mes de mayo en plena
ola de calor en la ciudad más caliente
del mundo toda la población trata de
refrescarse lo mejor que puede a pesar
de las temperaturas récord los obreros
siguen trabajando garmendia que trabajar
con este calor es muy difícil a veces
cuando trabajo me mareo siento que mi
cuerpo está agotado de toda su energía
pero no tengo elección si no gano dinero
no puedo alimentar a mi familia seguiré
haciendo este trabajo hasta que mi
cuerpo me lo permita
así su la cubra 700 rupias paquistaníes
al día por 8 horas de trabajo esto
apenas alcanza para alimentar a su
esposa y sus tres hijos
y aquí es donde dormimos sólo tenemos un
ventilador a menudo hay cortes de luz y
a veces durante seis horas no tenemos
electricidad así que tenemos que usar
este abanico el calor combinado con la
alta humedad hace la vida más
insoportable los desmayos son habituales
qué te está pasando estás variado
estabas al aire libre crees que has
cogido un golpe de calor
y
estos días tenemos sobre todo pacientes
que sufren de insolación tienen
gastroenteritis su presión arterial es
baja debido al calor aconsejamos a todos
que tomen precauciones en este momento
los que trabajan deben hacerlo en las
primeras horas de la mañana todo el
mundo debe evitar salir o trabajar por
la tarde cuando hacen mucho calor pero
ya cuba acumula los retos la ciudad es
una de las más pobres de pakistán y el
agua potable aquí está en manos de
mafias locales que la venden a la gente
desde principios de junio en bélgica la
vida de las mujeres en situación de
prostitución cambio ahora tienen los
mismos derechos que cualquier trabajador
con estatuto independiente y pueden así
acceder a la seguridad social bélgica se
convierte en el primer país europeo en
tomar esta medida y en el segundo en el
mundo después de nueva zelanda sin
embargo quienes se oponen a esta
legislación alegan que no protege a las
mujeres de los proxenetas
emma prefiere cambiar su nombre y
ocultar su cara a pesar de que desde
junio esta mujer de 29 años vive más
tranquila y abiertamente en bélgica el
país acaba de despenalizar la
prostitución como consecuencia emma
puede buscar un apartamento en el que
pueda ejercer legalmente lo que le
evitaría nuevas malas experiencias con
propietarios sin escrúpulos estaba
pagando mil 600 euros al mes todo en
efectivo por supuesto ni siquiera había
declarado el contrato por un apartamento
de 40 metros cuadrados
emma puede ceñirse bajo el estatuto de
trabajadora independiente de kutz podrá
cotizar para el seguro de desempleo
podré cotizar para la pensión
bélgica es el primer país europeo en
permitir que cualquiera se registre como
trabajador sexual y el segundo en el
mundo después de nueva zelanda en países
bajos la prostitución es legal pero la
ley es mucho más restrictiva o feto pib
a el fuego complir tu triste condición
de hecho en países bajos tienes que
reunir una amplia lista de condiciones
para poder ser considerada trabajadora
sexual por lo que muchas personas no
cumplen estas condiciones así que
trabajan en la
la pipa
azulada los opositores a esta
legislación alegan que no protege a las
víctimas de explotación sexual lujoso
objeto el proyecto continúa penalizando
el proxenetismo pero el problema es la
definición de este concepto la
definición con firefox para ser
considerado proxeneta tienes que hacer
un gran margen de beneficios sin embargo
esta noción es muy vaga y abierta a la
interpretación
un argumento que el ministro de justicia
belga rechaza porque este nuevo régimen
laboral sólo aplica quienes sean
autónomas no a dependientes más
vulnerables a la explotación sexual
discute que el sol eco estamos
discutiendo cuáles deberían ser las
condiciones para que las empresas
contraten a trabajadoras sexuales y ahí
especificaremos que es una relación
laboral normal y que es una relación de
abuso que esquía y no graso abusiva la
despenalización de la prostitución
también facilita que quienes la
practican puedan denunciar agresiones
ante la policía es el comienzo de una
nueva etapa para 26.000 personas en
bélgica
gracias por seguir un nuevo episodio de
corresponsales queremos agradecer a
templo t por prestarnos sus
instalaciones para la realización de
este programa y ustedes muchas gracias
por seguirlo nos damos cita la próxima
semana siga con más información en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom